على تيك توك هذه الايام منتشر ترند جديد
اسمه
هذا الترند هدفه يعلم الناس كيف تتحكم في
ميزانياتها ومصاريفها وفكره انه بدل
البطاقات نرجع للكاش يعني تسحب فلوسك كاش
وتحطها في مغلفات كل مغلف تحط فيه مصروف
شيء معين والترند بيقول انه كذا حتوفر
فلوس وهتصرف اقل لانه الدفع بالبطاقه
والجوال والساعه اللي تعودنا ندفع فيهم في
السنوات الاخيره هذه صار مدمرنا
الجامع على تيك توك تقريبا مليار مشاركه
اذان
الجديد لكن الكلام عن الفرق بين الدفع
بكاش او بالبطاقه مو جديد فمن زمان بنسمع
تعليقات عن كيف لما ندفع بالبطاقه بنصرف
اكثر بكثير حتى في نكت وميمز كثيره عن انه
الدفع بالكروت والتليفون كانه مو فلوسك
يعني
نحسب اكثر ايش بندفع احنا حبينا نعرف
رايكم في الموضوع وانه هل لما بتدفعوا
نفسكم بت نفقوا اكثر او لا ويبدو معظمكم
متفق مع الفكره والتراند فاجاباتكم جاءت
كالتالي 77% منكم قالوا نعم الدفع كاش
بخليهم يصرفوا اقل و 23% قالوا لا
نتكلم اكثر في هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستوديو زميلتنا الجديده في قسم
الاقتصاد نوف حجازي اهلا يا نوف منورتنا
طبعا انت احدث المنضمين للقناه واحدث
المندمنين لقسم الاقتصاد تحديدا طبعا
دايما بنتمنى لك التوفيق طبعا نورتنا واول
مره تصير معنا كمان انت معارضه لدى
الموضوع
اولا بدي اقول انه انا يعني
مسؤوله عن الصرف ومساريكي وكيف بتديري
بالك على الموضوع بس انا بحس انه لو معي
كاش ما عمري بقدر يعني اتابع او تتراك وين
صرفت هذا الكاش
لما يكون مثلا عم بصرف على انه هو تاب تاب
تاب تاب بس كل مره
على هذا الاماونت باقي بحسابك هذا الامان
بالعكس دائما بيعطيني انه زي ما بيقولوا
ريالي تيتشك انه باخر اليوم
بصحيك معك
اليوم طيب معلش خليني اقول لك كمان شيء
ثاني مثلا في ناس زيي هذه المسجات لما
تيجي كده
فالناس اللي زيي يعني كده يمكن احنا
مختلفين انت كل خلفيتك يعني شو شغلك في
البزنس وكده فاكيد حتكوني يعني اوعى مننا
في موضوع ايوه شوي مسؤوله اكثر في موضوع
الفلوس ما تحسي هذا الشيء يعني
لما يفتحوا المحفظه يشوفوا مثلا انا كان
معاي هالقد كاش خلص كل الكاش اللي معي وين
راحوا مصاري بس
بضل انه حسب قد انت عامله لي مثل حالك
يعني مثلا لو هلا انت معك هذا الامام
افكاش
لساتني عراقيه بحس انه لما انا باخر اليوم
افتح مثلا ماي بنك اكاونت واشوف انه هل
صرفت او بس هالقد ضل معي بفكر انه هي وين
راحوا وين صرفت مصاري فبرجع بشوف مثلا
بالمسجز او عالاب او
انا صرفت على هيك وهيك وهيك وهيك وبيطلع
لك بالضبط وين رحتي
هذا المنظر
بس انه للاسف
كمان خليني ارجع اقول لك ليش تفسري الناس
انه فعلا زي ما وصفتي كده انت لما بيفتحوا
المحفظه وبيلاقوا ان الفلوس خلصت انه
بيشعروا انه يعني لا هم صرفوا اكثر
والكلام هذا كله ليش الشعور هذا
نفسيا
من محفظتك وتدفعي بتحسي حالك انه انا
راح تفتح المحفظه او الظرف اطلعي انه
المصاري فيه قلت فهذا يعني كمان بعطيك
شعور زي كانك مصاريكي عم يخلصوا صح بس
يعني بيعود الامر
شو انت بتفضلي انا بعرف ناس يمكن
بعائلتي ابدا ما بستعملوا
متعودين انه خلص هذا
المبلغ من الكاش الا لما اصرف منه هذا ما
تبقى لي
ولكن انا بالنسبه
كثير مرات مثلا بسافر على بلد معين ما بدي
اشرف بالكويت بكون محوله مبلغ مصاري فعلا
ما بعرف وين راح ما بعرف وين صرفت المصاري
عن شو صرفتهم
مثلا يعني بيحسسك انه اه نفس المبلغ كانها
نفس العمله عندنا وهي ثلاثة أربع اضعاف في
المبلغ طيب في ناس فعلا بياخذوا هذا
القرار لما بيصير عندهم مشاكل في الكريدت
كارد انه يوقفوا الكريدت كارد تماما من
حياتهم وبس يصرفوا اللي موجود عندهم طيب
يعني انت نصيحتك انه نستمر بس نقرا
الرسائل حقت البانكو وبحسبها ضروري عشان
ما يطلع لك صدمه يعني باخر الشهر شوفي هو
انا دائما مصدومه يوميا مصدومه بموضوع
الفلوس ده يوميا مصدومه واقول لنفسي كيف
يا ساره صرفتي هذه الاشياء ولكن المهم
تنبسطي الله
ليه ليه بتقولي ده الكلام من اول يا
نوفلنا البدايه اسمي نعيش مره الله عليك
ما في العالم شكرا لك كانت معنا زميلتنا
اللي حتفضح انها حتكون معانا ضيفه مستمره
بعد الكلام الاخير هذا انه في حجازي شكرا
لك شكرا ساره
[موسيقى]